Das ist wirklich eine absolute premiere zum ersten mal wird ein ganz normales oder zumindest fast normales auto ins all fliegen
Und jetzt kommt es zum mars geschickt
Was ist jetzt wieder los mit allen masc die ihnen mars chroniken jetzt bei klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Ja es gibt so
Unglaublich viele bei ihnen macht zu berichten und ihr interessiert euch ziemlich für diesen wirklich schillernden unternehmen und alles was um ihn herum passiert
Alles was er anpackt wird außergewöhnlich und immer wieder verblüfft mit unglaublichen ideen bahnbrechende rekorden und
Innovationen mit denen so keiner gerechnet hätte deshalb machen wir jetzt eine eigene rubrik auf hierbei klicks um die ihnen masco nicken
los geht's
Ja nur noch ein paar tage dann startet der jungfernflug der falcon heavy und das ist schon etwas ganz besonderes
Es kam nicht ein wenig verwirrung darum aber es scheint tatsächlich
Wirklichkeit, zu werden ihnen masken seinen eigenen tesla roadster in den weltraum schicken aber nicht nur den dazu
Gleich mehr es geht
Um den ersten flug der falcon heavy der größten rakete der welt die ein neues zeitalter der raumfahrt
einläuten wird doch bei diesem testflug soll keine nutzlast transportiert werden denn das risiko
wäre
Zu gross dass sie zerstört wird dabei ist es erst vor wenigen tagen ein
Missgeschick passiert eine falcon 9. Hat ihre wertvolle fracht verloren den milliardenteuren
Spionagesatelliten zu mehr soll in der atmosphäre verglüht sein ob das aber tatsächlich so passiert ist und wege
spionagesatellit und wenn ja was dort genau geschehen ist dass es unklar spacex jedenfalls schießt eine fehlfunktion der
Falcon 9. Aus jetzt also schon ende januar eine neue
Rekordleistung die falcon heavy sie ist absolut
Rekordverdächtig kann man gar nicht sagen rekord gewiss keine rakete kann so viel nutzlast transportieren also keine aktuelle je nach ort
Kann, sie bis zu 63 8 tonnen last in den weltraum bringen das ist immens bei der felke neuen sind es
22,8 tonnen also nur ein drittel einen mast hatte sich vorgenommen bei diesem ersten test etwas vollkommen verrücktes in den weltraum zu fliegen
Und dann hat er sich entschieden es soll sein tesla roadster sein er gehört zur ersten generation
Roadster und wurde 2009 produziert seitdem wurde er von mas gefahren und jetzt wird es
eine strecke zurücklegen die noch nie ein auto
Zurücklegt hat absolut verrückt aber noch verrückter ist das was ihnen maskin das auto gepackt hat die audio anlage
wird space oddity von david bowie spielen und im handschuhfach
Ist eine ausgabe vom per anhalter durch die galaxis von douglas adams und ein handtuch mit der aufschrift keine panik
ziel ist der mars und der roadster wird für zitat für
milliarden von jahren in den tiefen des alls schweben so musk wenn die rakete nicht beim start
Explodiert meint erweitert man muss es ihnen musk lassen er hat auch noch sind für zur zeit wird alles für den start
Vorbereitet und es wird ein historisches ereignis die falcon
Heavy wird von der startrampe staaten von der die saturn 5 die ersten astronauten zum mond gebracht hat
Es wird also geschichte geschrieben in wenigen tagen wenn er kein video zu diesem historischen ereignis verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier
ein aber aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch immer über neue in videos informiert hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
1000 raketen zum mars da geht es um noch so ein paar kleine ideen von allen masc ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran